[SPEAKER_03]: You have a good one.
[SPEAKER_03]: Hosted 9.30 for a 9 a.m. email.
[SPEAKER_03]: Locked it down.
Thank you.
[SPEAKER_09]: That's what I always seen her clean her grass with.
[SPEAKER_09]: She didn't have no teeth either.
[SPEAKER_04]: She used it on her grass instead of her mouth.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, I know.
[SPEAKER_05]: Mom always used grass.
Other people have all kinds of grass.
[SPEAKER_09]: Yeah, she can make a chocolate pie that my wife cannot cut.
[SPEAKER_09]: She's trying.
but there was something else that wanted that recipe.
[SPEAKER_06]: She may have left it out on purpose.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes, exactly.
[SPEAKER_06]: That way you can never duplicate Mama's pie.
[SPEAKER_09]: Oh, Granny would make a chocolate bread head meringue.
Hello.
[SPEAKER_06]: Sure, that would be great.
[SPEAKER_06]: And the other one we never did.
[SPEAKER_06]: She never got back with us.
[SPEAKER_06]: something came up just this morning and she said she said she could come later in the day but it would be late afternoon and i thought it would be hard to get us all so because i'm gone next week but thanks
[SPEAKER_09]: It's that time of year when I was taking a vacation.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm going to try to.
[SPEAKER_09]: You know, that's something I can honestly say I've never been on, is vacation.
[SPEAKER_09]: Don't start now.
[SPEAKER_09]: No, there's no sense.
[SPEAKER_09]: You might like it.
[SPEAKER_09]: Well, yeah.
[SPEAKER_09]: Just like retirement, I didn't think I'd like it.
[SPEAKER_09]: I love it.
[SPEAKER_09]: You see that look?
because I don't have skillful shoes.
We tried.
[SPEAKER_06]: We tried to keep it that way.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, so tomorrow.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, that's perfect.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's going to be a windy day.
[SPEAKER_09]: Boy.
[SPEAKER_06]: I went outside probably before 7 to feed the animals and just dogs.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's not like I had any chickens or anything, so I didn't want to get anything I was saying that I did.
[SPEAKER_06]: But then I went out and watered some flowers on my front porch 45 minutes later, and the difference was just like, wow.
[SPEAKER_08]: I had to water before I left.
[SPEAKER_06]: It's amazing how they, it doesn't take very long.
[SPEAKER_08]: These glass samples are going back to Butch,
[SPEAKER_08]: Morning.
[SPEAKER_08]: Did you sign in?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: I forgot to get you the links to this podcast about the data center stuff.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: We're missing Bree this morning, so Max is going to...
[SPEAKER_05]: Just kind of a metal, earthy, kind of like what Muskie would just tell.
[SPEAKER_08]: It wasn't slug cakes, was it?
[SPEAKER_06]: It better not be.
[SPEAKER_06]: Where were they?
[SPEAKER_06]: We don't know anything about it.
[SPEAKER_06]: No, it was not that.
[SPEAKER_06]: It was just probably more of an earth bead.
[SPEAKER_08]: That's a new pot of plant because the umbrella blew over and knocked the pot of plant over upside down.
[SPEAKER_06]: When I know it's gonna rain, I pull my pot, my little pots out, my big pots on the front porch and set it out on the gravel of the landscaping.
[SPEAKER_06]: And I'll tell you, the wind can play heck with those pots, because they're not going to be like, yeah, might go out there and they're sideways.
[SPEAKER_06]: They probably didn't get any of the rain that was in my bottom.
[SPEAKER_08]: I make a motion to go into session.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'll second it.
[SPEAKER_03]: Father God, we thank you for another beautiful day to experience your goodness and grace, and we just pray your blessing upon this county.
[SPEAKER_03]: We ask, Lord, that you would be with all of our elected officials and workers of the county, that you would give them wisdom and discernment today to make the very best choices and decisions for the county on behalf of the people.
[SPEAKER_03]: Lord, we just pray that you would guide and direct them.
[SPEAKER_03]: We pray ahead to protection around them and their families and just keep them safe and healthy.
[SPEAKER_03]: Pray for the citizens of our community and of our county and just pray that you would unite us together in a common good, seeking your will and pursuing after what is right and good and true in all that we do.
[SPEAKER_03]: We just pray your blessing upon the county as a whole and upon this day.
[SPEAKER_03]: We look forward with great anticipation to all you have in store for us today.
[SPEAKER_03]: We ask all these things in Jesus' name.
[SPEAKER_03]: Amen.
[SPEAKER_09]: I have an issue with... Do you mind if I sit down?
[SPEAKER_09]: My knees are killing me.
[SPEAKER_09]: It's fine.
[SPEAKER_09]: Thank you.
[SPEAKER_06]: We'll ask questions if we can't hear.
[SPEAKER_09]: I own and operate the Hillside Track Range over on 112th Street, just right next to the Clayton-Gregg County line.
[SPEAKER_09]: And...
[SPEAKER_09]: That gravel road is a menace for hill junglers.
[SPEAKER_09]: I mean a menace.
[SPEAKER_09]: And they'll come from the Clay County side, they'll run the stop sign at the county line, and they'll come over that hill there at my sister's house, and I mean they are flipping airborne.
[SPEAKER_09]: Two weeks ago Sunday, after we got done shooting,
[SPEAKER_09]: one of my shooters pulled out and was going to go up the hill to leave.
[SPEAKER_09]: And he dang near got T-bumped.
[SPEAKER_09]: I mean, dang near.
[SPEAKER_09]: That guy was going so fast in a red Chevrolet pickup.
[SPEAKER_09]: He was going so fast, he could not get stopped.
[SPEAKER_09]: And, I mean, David was already in his turn when he come over that hill.
[SPEAKER_06]: So are there stop signs there?
[SPEAKER_09]: signs at the county line.
[SPEAKER_09]: But whenever they come over that hill, they're driving so fast.
[SPEAKER_09]: I mean, I would bet if Gary had a radar gun, he could shoot them 70, 80 miles an hour.
[SPEAKER_09]: Easy.
[SPEAKER_09]: I mean, easy.
[SPEAKER_09]: And another thing, my shooters, whenever they're it's 400 feet from the top of that hill to the driveway.
[SPEAKER_09]: Okay, which is in county statutes.
[SPEAKER_09]: And because Elvis, when Elvis was here, he's the one that measured it off because he's the one that put the color on it.
[SPEAKER_09]: And they drive through there daily like this.
[SPEAKER_09]: I want to propose that half a mile stretch from the Ray Clay County line east
[SPEAKER_09]: Now, I know what everybody's saying.
[SPEAKER_09]: The county don't have no jurisdiction set speed limits.
[SPEAKER_09]: Well, I talked to the state, and I talked to MoDOT, and they both told me that any county road, they do not set speed limits on county roads.
[SPEAKER_09]: MoDOT nor the state.
[SPEAKER_09]: That also comes to being true because in Clay County, on the Clay County side, that is a blacktop road, and that's a 35 mile an hour road up to the stop sign there at the Clay-Ray County line.
[SPEAKER_09]: And it's been 30, it's posted 35, it's been 35 for years.
[SPEAKER_06]: But wouldn't the blacktop be moved up?
[SPEAKER_09]: No, no, no, no.
[SPEAKER_09]: But that's not what I'm saying.
[SPEAKER_09]: What I'm saying is, if the county's gonna set
[SPEAKER_09]: a speed limit of 55 mile an hour on a gravel road, why, how come Clay County, which is in the same state of Missouri, can set their speed limits at a different pace?
[SPEAKER_09]: Is that blacktop, is that in the city of Excelsior?
[SPEAKER_09]: No, no, no, no, no.
[SPEAKER_09]: It's more of a chip and seal.
[SPEAKER_09]: I said blacktop, but it's more of a chip and seal.
[SPEAKER_09]: But anyway, the state representative that I talked to, the MoDOT person that I talked to, Bo Staley,
[SPEAKER_09]: has to be the county to set the speed limit on the gravel roads.
[SPEAKER_09]: And the speed limit on the gravel roads in Brake County is 55 mile an hour, which I think is silly anyway.
[SPEAKER_09]: But I don't do it.
[SPEAKER_09]: I just pay my taxes.
[SPEAKER_09]: I'm not part of the Senate board or whatever you want to call it.
[SPEAKER_09]: But what I'm proposing is
[SPEAKER_09]: That area right there, that half a mile from the Clay Red County line, east on 112th Street, if you could please help me out and drop the speed limit on that where Gary could do something about these people that are driving so fast through there.
[SPEAKER_09]: I mean, they're terrible.
[SPEAKER_09]: You could come over there.
[SPEAKER_09]: I'm inviting you to come over and sit in my driveway just all day.
[SPEAKER_09]: Yeah, and she got hit head-on because of a hill jumper back in 06, you know, right there on the, pretty much the same hill.
[SPEAKER_06]: Is this just hill jumpers that know that road that's there?
[SPEAKER_06]: Oh, yeah.
[SPEAKER_09]: And they live, and the biggest majority of these people that drive like a banshee through there, they live over there in Deerhead.
[SPEAKER_09]: That's where they live.
[SPEAKER_09]: That's the biggest part of it.
[SPEAKER_09]: Now, where all of them live, I couldn't tell you.
[SPEAKER_09]: But, it's just like this, you know,
[SPEAKER_09]: I'm wanting to protect my shooters.
[SPEAKER_09]: I don't want to lose business.
[SPEAKER_09]: I don't want to get another phone call saying, you need to do something about the people that drive like a banshee through here because of what me and my daughter went through.
[SPEAKER_09]: Because he's not coming back.
[SPEAKER_09]: And that's losing me business.
[SPEAKER_09]: And another thing, these people know what they're doing because they'll drive by like a banshee.
[SPEAKER_09]: on my shoot because the shooters can't see the targets that they're shooting at.
[SPEAKER_09]: You know, they play targets because of the depth that they're stirring up.
[SPEAKER_09]: And so, you know, I'm losing time there too.
[SPEAKER_06]: You know, I don't know the answer to your question in my almost two years.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't think we've ever had that question posed to us and I'll speak on it some way.
[SPEAKER_08]: I'm just working in, let's say, 55, if not more.
[SPEAKER_09]: That's exactly what it says.
[SPEAKER_06]: But I'm just trying to keep my... Are you saying you think 55 is okay?
[SPEAKER_09]: No, I'm saying 55 is way too fast on Grouton Road.
[SPEAKER_09]: And I said something to Clay Clevenger, which is in charge of the bridge and road.
[SPEAKER_09]: He said he would have no problem putting up a sign.
[SPEAKER_09]: a speed limit sign.
[SPEAKER_09]: You know, one right there at the hill at my sister's and then basically one right at my driveway where they could see it going both ways.
[SPEAKER_09]: You know, and like I said, it's just a half a mile stretch.
[SPEAKER_09]: And I don't see why it's going to kill anybody to slow down and do the speed limit for a half a mile.
[SPEAKER_09]: But the point I'm getting at is Gary says until...
[SPEAKER_09]: I'm not quite sure how he said that.
[SPEAKER_09]: But until there is something...
[SPEAKER_09]: speeding through there, because he has nothing to go on.
[SPEAKER_09]: Well, if you drop that speed limit down to a sensible speed, seeing as how the public is going in and out of that driveway and such, if you drop that speed limit down to a sensible speed, then Yuri can do something about it, because he can drive him for a C-9, which is careless and improved driving, you know, for driving too fast.
[SPEAKER_06]: And by the way, we are being recorded both video and audio, so I did not make that happen.
[SPEAKER_09]: I'm cool with that.
[SPEAKER_06]: I guess we need to consider it.
[SPEAKER_06]: I also, I wonder how many of those extraordinary cases...
[SPEAKER_06]: it would be in red county that we would then need to address it a lot of times in other areas yeah yeah right so um we'll have to discuss it we'll discuss it and maybe maybe um
[SPEAKER_06]: reach out to travis just to tell him we're considering this travis is our our legal counsel and um he knows what other counties are doing so we'll look into it and see what but i mean i hope i'm not throwing some kind of a
[SPEAKER_09]: Yeah, I'm just trying to keep people safe.
[SPEAKER_06]: We want that too.
[SPEAKER_06]: So we will discuss it.
[SPEAKER_06]: We will reach out to him for his opinion and see if he has any...
[SPEAKER_06]: Sometimes he has some ideas of what somebody else is doing, like Max says, and that is working.
[SPEAKER_06]: So we will consider it and...
[SPEAKER_06]: Did you put your number on them?
[SPEAKER_08]: On the contact number?
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: With a car counter, a car counter.
[SPEAKER_02]: I think that's what they call them when they put them over the roads where they count the cars.
[SPEAKER_02]: You see the traffic that comes through.
[SPEAKER_09]: Oh, that, that hundred and plus street since, you know, used to, you know, back when mama and daddy had this track range, you know, back,
[SPEAKER_09]: and you've got the, you know, the, you know, the building, all the buildings went up around Shack Creek.
[SPEAKER_09]: That is one, I mean, there's no, there's times like, well, just like last Wednesday night, we sat there and the Shears and I just basically had to shut everything down.
[SPEAKER_09]: We sat there and watched five vehicles, bang, bang, just right behind each other, just driving crazy and just had to sit there.
[SPEAKER_09]: be able to start shooting again.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, we appreciate hearing from you, and we will talk about it, and we have your number.
[SPEAKER_09]: We'll give you a call.
[SPEAKER_09]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_09]: Thank you very much.
I'm sorry.
[SPEAKER_06]: Did you bring your toothpaste?
I didn't bring it.
[SPEAKER_06]: Nobody fell.
I can't leave until they leave us.
All right.
[SPEAKER_09]: Well, I appreciate you for hearing me out.
[SPEAKER_09]: If you've got any questions, you can call that number.
[SPEAKER_09]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: My sweet meal.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you guys have the ability to post on that website or does everything that's posted on there have to be sent to the people that run it?
[SPEAKER_06]: I didn't understand what your question was.
[SPEAKER_00]: The website, do you guys have the ability to post on that website or does everything have to be sent away to the company that runs that?
[SPEAKER_06]: We send it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: That is correct.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then, so I was looking around and I saw there's the public notices or the legal notices page now.
[SPEAKER_00]: How long has that been used?
[SPEAKER_00]: Because it looks like the earliest thing on there is from April 27th.
[SPEAKER_00]: I can't tell if it's like...
[SPEAKER_00]: things are being removed as time goes on or if that was the first time that we started posting notices on there.
[SPEAKER_06]: Are you talking about like planning and zoning notices?
[SPEAKER_00]: This one was for the jail bid.
[SPEAKER_00]: This one was the jail bid is on there and the janitorial RFP is there.
[SPEAKER_06]: you're saying it's still on there and we've already addressed it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, I'm just asking if that April 27th bid was the first time that was used.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't think so.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think we've put it on there before.
[SPEAKER_06]: Maybe it's not there now because it was removed.
[SPEAKER_08]: Probably needs to be updated.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, yeah.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, then I guess my main question there is, like, is the digital or, like, physical notices priority for the county to get information out to the public?
[SPEAKER_08]: This bulletin board right out here is the official announcement.
[SPEAKER_08]: Everything else is a courtesy.
[SPEAKER_08]: Courtesy.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so the agenda for today wasn't posted with 24 hours of notice, which is required by law.
[SPEAKER_00]: And also the one that's published on the website says it's published at one time and it's actually published at another.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I'm just letting you guys know that that is happening.
[SPEAKER_00]: Even on the page itself it says post it at 9.30 when the meeting starts at 9 o'clock.
[SPEAKER_00]: So that's less than 24 hours of notice.
[SPEAKER_07]: And it wasn't because...
[SPEAKER_05]: or you're not being here.
[SPEAKER_08]: Right, we're in transition and we're working on that, but thank you.
[SPEAKER_00]: So then the other question that I had was about remedy for like sunshine requests that are being answered properly.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I think in January I submitted a sunshine request that was about getting a compilation of the county ordinances to Heather
[SPEAKER_00]: When she responded, she gave me one from the previous commission, which then I resubmitted whenever Lindsay took over as the custodian of records.
[SPEAKER_00]: And she said there was nothing else besides that.
[SPEAKER_00]: But then I went and looked around and found an archive of
[SPEAKER_00]: older ordinances so I and this is not the only example of that that I have so I'm trying to figure out like if I make a sunshine request and then it isn't really fulfilled and then
[SPEAKER_00]: What am I supposed to do?
[SPEAKER_00]: I wouldn't know that that information would even exist or where it was if I hadn't been looking around for it outside of the county, but those are county records.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I don't know what I'm supposed to do in that scenario.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm not sure what the answer to that is.
[SPEAKER_08]: I guess we'll have to investigate that and get you an answer.
[SPEAKER_06]: I know...
[SPEAKER_06]: systems from years and years and years ago is mostly get in there and hunt and find them.
[SPEAKER_06]: And I'm not sure how they go together to where you have what's on digitally now and what's in the files.
[SPEAKER_06]: So I'm not sure what the answer is.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: Um, and then, so like the last thing that I had was basically, so on March 11th and the agenda is whenever you guys brought up originally the, this was cause I was looking back through old notes from meetings.
[SPEAKER_00]: Um, the agenda has that commissioners discuss, um,
[SPEAKER_00]: Sunshine request charges, and then you guys tabled it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I was at that meeting and tried to ask questions, but you guys said you're tabling it to get more legal advice.
[SPEAKER_00]: Then on the 16th, there's nothing about sunshine request changes, and then you guys adopted this sunshine request law resolution, which changes the charges and appoints a
[SPEAKER_00]: custodian of records and about prepayment and stuff like that.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I was trying to figure out, like, why was that resolution adopted if the public wasn't allowed to really comment on it?
[SPEAKER_06]: We have had several discussions as we adopted that resolution.
[SPEAKER_00]: But it wasn't on the agenda, so the public wouldn't know.
[SPEAKER_06]: But it was something that was tabled that we brought back.
[SPEAKER_06]: And I think we can do that.
[SPEAKER_06]: If it's tabled.
[SPEAKER_06]: if it's tabled today, we might not bring it back tomorrow.
[SPEAKER_06]: But when we're ready for it, we can bring it back because it was already listed on the agenda.
[SPEAKER_06]: I believe.
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm not an attorney, but I believe that we can do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I guess what you're saying is that if I had interest in something on March 11th that was tabled that day, I would have to attend every single meeting until April 16th?
[SPEAKER_08]: Let's go back to...
[SPEAKER_00]: I wanted to know I wanted to know what was going on with the charges actually whenever this was published when it said charges I didn't think of it as money I thought of it as
[SPEAKER_00]: an accusation.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I was like, what is, what are they being charged with?
[SPEAKER_00]: But, um, so yeah, uh, it was, well, obviously it wasn't that once the, uh, request, sunshine request process, uh, was changed.
[SPEAKER_00]: So yeah, I just wanted to know what was going on, um, really and figure out and figure that out.
[SPEAKER_00]: But there was no public notice that this was being discussed.
[SPEAKER_08]: resolution was for was to put it back in line with state statute.
[SPEAKER_00]: I do.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: But I'm asking, though, like, in that case, and especially with the table, like, about tabling and then not putting things on agenda, what you're saying is that if I had an interest in a topic that was tabled on March 11th, I would have had to attend every single meeting until April 16th.
[SPEAKER_08]: We'll double-check the protocols on that.
[SPEAKER_00]: I know what you're doing is legal.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm just saying that's kind of like...
[SPEAKER_00]: You can see how that's difficult for a citizen to...
[SPEAKER_00]: Most people can't even come to one meeting a week like I do, let alone...
[SPEAKER_00]: All right, I hear you.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you for your comment.
[SPEAKER_00]: So regarding that resolution, it doesn't specifically say who the custodian of records is, but I know you guys have it posted over there.
[SPEAKER_00]: So I was wondering what was the process for choosing Lindsay as the custodian?
[SPEAKER_06]: It seemed like the...
[SPEAKER_06]: The person that she's been here, she's been here for quite a while.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't know how many years, but it just seemed like she was in that rotation order where she could spend some time with it because of trying to, a lot of sunshine requests.
[SPEAKER_06]: We're trying to divvy up time for people to do what needs to be done to fulfill those desires.
[SPEAKER_00]: when she's in the first office so I think that kind of answers why and not the question that I asked which is about the process because I agree like she's the best person but like did you guys vote on it was there public discussion was like what was the we appoint this person it's administrative change anyone in this office could be that person and it will probably vary the reason it wasn't voted on it wasn't put in the resolution is because it may change from time to time
[SPEAKER_08]: Because, for example, she will be having a baby one of these days, and so someone will have to take her place.
[SPEAKER_08]: At that point, she's no longer in custody when she comes back.
[SPEAKER_08]: So we left ourselves room to change that name.
[SPEAKER_00]: So it's you, the commissioners, that choose who that is, not the...
[SPEAKER_08]: It'll be the commissioners.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: But no vote will be had on it?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's just like...
[SPEAKER_00]: one of you okay so okay okay i think that covers everything that i had let me make sure yeah yep that's everything thank you okay we have some invoices too thank you i need to slam that door
[SPEAKER_07]: Does it turn on?
[SPEAKER_06]: No.
[SPEAKER_06]: The computer's bright alone, maybe Saturday.
Great.
[SPEAKER_08]: Have you seen that used to get a little horned?
Let's hold this.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think so too.
[SPEAKER_04]: Was that just trap shooting or was it all shooting?
[SPEAKER_04]: Can we take our guns out there and do target practicing?
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_07]: It's not just for the school.
[SPEAKER_04]: And just normal, like we can take our 9mm out there and do target practicing?
[SPEAKER_07]: Or is it trap shooting?
[SPEAKER_07]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_07]: I know he was talking about plagues, but...
or can we just
[SPEAKER_08]: Thank you.
Thank you.
[SPEAKER_07]: that we didn't want to do, but we did.
[SPEAKER_07]: This one I don't know how much longer to say about, but I'm definitely approved, so that brings me to the company for 395.
[SPEAKER_07]: and it was just an invoice that I got, so I asked them that in the jail where it was for, and they said the materials to replace the kitchen sink faucet was found.
[SPEAKER_07]: And I said, is this part of the approved things to jail improvements?
[SPEAKER_07]: So I told them that you all might not approve that, but if you didn't, you'd have to come to a jail line.
That's just maintenance, isn't it?
[SPEAKER_07]: I mean, that's just maintenance.
[SPEAKER_07]: I say.
[SPEAKER_07]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'll put it over there.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'll put a note on it.
[SPEAKER_07]: I'm just letting you know victory technology still hasn't been faked.
[SPEAKER_07]: Now, I know what the email said.
[SPEAKER_07]: It's just for the inside.
[SPEAKER_07]: And you said you wanted to talk on the phone.
[SPEAKER_06]: The inside was the judge.
[SPEAKER_07]: Wouldn't quit, but installing it too?
[SPEAKER_07]: Yeah, the whole thing.
[SPEAKER_07]: Then I will tell Franken that this is the judge's.
[SPEAKER_07]: And you'll have the same.
[SPEAKER_07]: And let him take it.
[SPEAKER_08]: And when they do the elevator, that's supposed to be the chair's part.
[SPEAKER_08]: Which one?
[SPEAKER_08]: The address, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: And it may be maintenance too, just maintaining, I mean.
[SPEAKER_08]: I think framing was what's going on.
[SPEAKER_07]: And just to let them know, this homestead that you all approved for, you know, the H-1A, Connie said don't pay it until she got Homestead to sign.
[SPEAKER_07]: That homestead is still on time.
[SPEAKER_07]: So even though you all approved it, Homestead had to go to their park so I can't pay it.
Yeah.
Okay.
Keep the money in the bank.
Yep.
[SPEAKER_06]: Did we make a decision, and I know we tabled it, but we're going to talk about it a little bit, the presentation that the rural water
[SPEAKER_06]: people on...
[SPEAKER_06]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_06]: It was here two weeks ago.
[SPEAKER_06]: It was in the paper.
[SPEAKER_06]: Did we make a decision on what we were doing there?
[SPEAKER_08]: No, we wanted to change and I don't see a reason for that.
[SPEAKER_06]: So we just decided that we did not need to take any action.
[SPEAKER_08]: Well,
[SPEAKER_08]: He wanted the water district fee way that they would put money in an account and that there was damage when they pay out that account.
[SPEAKER_08]: It just makes a lot of money for everybody.
[SPEAKER_08]: The issue is they don't do their own work.
[SPEAKER_08]: They hire a contractor.
[SPEAKER_08]: If they were doing their own work, the commission might consider waiving the fee because they're a county water district.
[SPEAKER_08]: However, they're hiring a private individual to do the work.
[SPEAKER_08]: So the private individual is purchasing the permit.
[SPEAKER_08]: And so at that point, the private individual should purchase the permit.
[SPEAKER_08]: So we were not going to waive it.
[SPEAKER_06]: So we're not making any changes?
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't think so.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, okay.
[SPEAKER_08]: We're not doing it.
[SPEAKER_06]: Do we have anything else that we're going to do some review on those bills?
[SPEAKER_06]: We're going to do some...
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay, well...
[SPEAKER_08]: So when we're looking at these buildings and making changes or, you know, in the case of the old jail, we've talked about putting it on the market.
[SPEAKER_08]: In the case of the administrative office, they need some upgrading, but it's
[SPEAKER_08]: maybe a accessible restroom or office space, however it gets rearranged or however that works.
[SPEAKER_08]: I'm not an architect, but I don't know.
[SPEAKER_08]: I think there's probably somebody who can make recommendations to us that we can consider.
[SPEAKER_08]: But at this point, I don't feel that confident being the one to walk in there and say, let's do this.
[SPEAKER_08]: I don't do that kind of thing.
[SPEAKER_08]: That's what I'm going to do.
[SPEAKER_06]: But I'm not sure how sophisticated someone, we're not builders at all.
[SPEAKER_06]: Like, we're not attorneys.
[SPEAKER_06]: But I'm not sure how sophisticated a builder would have to be to say, to look at it and say, this is some things.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, unless you want to get an architect.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't want to get into a big expense.
[SPEAKER_08]: Yeah, I mean, there's a lot of money.
[SPEAKER_08]: Because you're not going to get anything for it other than an opinion.
[SPEAKER_06]: And...
[SPEAKER_06]: My, just my opinion is if when you start getting into that, just like in an old house, you start taking this out and adding this, I mean, all of a sudden your $20,000 project is $120,000.
[SPEAKER_06]: If, you know, the part that bothers me about the more expensive bid that we had to get that, what they wanted, that was what they wanted, is...
[SPEAKER_06]: would they have to shut down to do it?
[SPEAKER_06]: Or are they saying if they kept that old bathroom in there and made a file written out of it, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_06]: Or if they did the new one that they wanted to do, which was maybe $16,000, wasn't it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: To me...
[SPEAKER_06]: that would be the easiest answer.
[SPEAKER_06]: It would give them their immediate need and us not getting into it.
[SPEAKER_06]: But I was worried about the, what is it, an asbestos.
[SPEAKER_06]: We went into the old bathroom, they thought there was going to be asbestos and they were going to have to close down and it couldn't work and all of that.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think it's important that whatever we do, they're able to work while they're doing it because they're always behind me.
[SPEAKER_06]: Can't keep up on everything.
[SPEAKER_08]: That's just my two cents.
[SPEAKER_06]: But if they start from scratch as a build-on, you might not have that, correct?
[SPEAKER_06]: If we just came in here and did a mall and a...
[SPEAKER_08]: And the tile on the floor.
[SPEAKER_08]: Yeah, and we don't touch it.
[SPEAKER_08]: Yeah, just cover it up.
[SPEAKER_08]: If you're not working on the exterior walls, not pulling the ceiling down, it has a suspended ceiling, so I think that's a good idea.
[SPEAKER_06]: I guess my opinion, I would just rather spend $16,000 than dig into it very much and all of a sudden it's $60,000 at least to make changes.
[SPEAKER_06]: That's just one opinion.
[SPEAKER_06]: It was through soccer.
[SPEAKER_06]: And he had one.
[SPEAKER_06]: The other one was under that threshold.
[SPEAKER_06]: It was $10,000 to fix the old bathroom, which was still going to be, honestly, it's a push for a handicap.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's what I said.
[SPEAKER_06]: I thought it was going to be a file room or something.
Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: There was something included in the bid that was kind of a bar area because we were saying, when we were trying to justify going back to the lesser bid, we said, do we really need a bar area for coffee or whatever?
[SPEAKER_06]: That's the way I took our discussion.
[SPEAKER_06]: But if we have somebody come in and give us their opinion, we may spend $5,000 right off the bat just for an opinion that we know and not have anything.
[SPEAKER_08]: I don't remember how wide the doors are to get there.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think he gave us a drawing.
[SPEAKER_06]: What?
[SPEAKER_06]: On that $60,000 bid.
[SPEAKER_06]: On that $60,000 bid that...
[SPEAKER_06]: would hit all those parameters that we need to do.
[SPEAKER_06]: That was probably from a year ago.
[SPEAKER_06]: From Stockton.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, you don't have to do that right now, but if you could get that, maybe we could have more discussion.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, this has been tabled several times.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_08]: No, I mean, we talked to SAP, and he said he'll call me back when we get closer.
[SPEAKER_08]: I'm not hanging my hat on him.
[SPEAKER_08]: And I haven't put together the other part of it yet.
[SPEAKER_06]: And we haven't heard back from Vance.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: I think we called him.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, I think we...
[SPEAKER_08]: I did call, but he didn't answer my message.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, maybe if they got rid of calling from the commission, do you think they would get their attention?
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, it's been a year.
[SPEAKER_06]: We did what we said we would do for them to come back in.
[SPEAKER_08]: They're just dragging us along.
[SPEAKER_06]: and we did our work in September, that work will need to be done again.
[SPEAKER_06]: And do we have anything else that we want to address today?
[SPEAKER_06]: I'm on one of my computers.
[SPEAKER_06]: No, it just came on.
[SPEAKER_06]: It was just, it was not looking good.
[SPEAKER_06]: Do you know Melissa's email?
[SPEAKER_06]: I could forward this, but we have an opioid.
[SPEAKER_06]: She was asking about that this morning.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, I found it.
[SPEAKER_05]: M.holloway at treasure.rakenmo.
[SPEAKER_05]: Go.
[SPEAKER_05]: There it is.
[SPEAKER_08]: Good, how are you?
[SPEAKER_07]: I'm pretty quiet today.
[SPEAKER_06]: No rally with you?
[SPEAKER_05]: I honestly don't think I've seen that.
[SPEAKER_05]: I do.
[SPEAKER_05]: I think she's going to sit in with me.
[SPEAKER_05]: And we need to be right in this.
[SPEAKER_05]: and we need a motion to table approving the minutes
[SPEAKER_06]: Until we get that.
[SPEAKER_08]: I make a motion to table until we figure out this computer issue.
[SPEAKER_06]: I second it.
[SPEAKER_06]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: All those in favor?
Aye.
[SPEAKER_04]: Did you guys end up turning an insurance claim in for that?
[SPEAKER_04]: If it was lightning?
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, we haven't.
[SPEAKER_04]: I think I might have a network switch.
[SPEAKER_04]: And that would be through PC app?
[SPEAKER_04]: Through Google?
[SPEAKER_05]: Uh-huh.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah.
Do you remember who you dealt with?
Was it both of them?
I'm not sure.
I don't remember.
I think that's who we called.
[SPEAKER_06]: I do not remember for sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: And it sounds like we might get more tonight.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yep, that's what they're saying.
[SPEAKER_06]: if you could give me that other resume for tomorrow.
[SPEAKER_06]: That'd be great.
[SPEAKER_06]: I don't, don't do it now.
[SPEAKER_05]: No, you don't have to call her another receiver or see her friends and those sorts of things.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm not sure.
[SPEAKER_06]: Like what we pay and what...
[SPEAKER_06]: So there's content that's listed on there.
[SPEAKER_05]: I would say that's one.
$7,000.
[SPEAKER_06]: $7,977.
$7,977.
[SPEAKER_06]: Maybe that's a typo.
[SPEAKER_06]: It should be $97,000 instead of $977,000.
Your question.
I don't know.
[SPEAKER_05]: Thank you so much.
[SPEAKER_08]: Yeah, well, I don't know.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, no detail until I get back.
[SPEAKER_08]: Anybody go to the soccer game last night?
[SPEAKER_06]: They said it was, I mean, it did look cool.
[SPEAKER_06]: nobody's in there, well, that's because they were on the highway.
[SPEAKER_06]: I mean, when it, actually, when it started, it was 69,000 people, is what I said.
[SPEAKER_06]: Yeah, they said, and the buses, of course.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: of people that aren't used to it you know chiefs crowds you know and they only gave them three hours from opening until start time you know that's not enough
[SPEAKER_08]: A lot of people have never been there.
[SPEAKER_06]: Well, and if you're Chiefs fans, they start going at 7 o'clock in the morning.
[SPEAKER_06]: You know, so it's just a little bit going in at a time versus... And you couldn't park anywhere close to the building.
[SPEAKER_08]: You know, the event.
[SPEAKER_08]: You had to park way out away from security.
[SPEAKER_06]: They interviewed some lady and she said, Kansas City, you have a problem.
[SPEAKER_06]: When you're trying to do that in a different...
[SPEAKER_06]: Kansas can deal with it.
[SPEAKER_06]: Which makes me sad.
[SPEAKER_08]: Kind of like the new airport, huh?
[SPEAKER_06]: Nope.
[SPEAKER_06]: Not at all.
[SPEAKER_06]: I wasn't sad for a minute on that one.
[SPEAKER_06]: Why not?
[SPEAKER_06]: I love the airport.
[SPEAKER_06]: And the other one was so inadequate.
[SPEAKER_06]: You have no idea how inadequate it was.
[SPEAKER_06]: It was so easy though.
[SPEAKER_06]: There was a whole lot more to it than easy.
[SPEAKER_06]: I would have bet, and I'm not a doubter, but I would have bet anything that I would have voted to keep the old one.
[SPEAKER_06]: I like fixing things and making it better.
[SPEAKER_06]: When you started looking at what was really inside that building, it was so inadequate.
[SPEAKER_06]: And it wasn't even, there were, well, to tell you, nothing is, everything is split, you know.
[SPEAKER_06]: The 12-4 and 12-8, that's the way things usually are.
[SPEAKER_06]: In that group, there were 25, and it was 23-2 to do a new one.
[SPEAKER_06]: You don't get that very often.
[SPEAKER_03]: I really enjoy Colorado Springs Airport.
[SPEAKER_03]: I'd rather fly out of there than Denver any time.
[SPEAKER_03]: Well, there are a lot of them that I... And walk up and walk in and get on.
[SPEAKER_06]: There are a lot of those small airports that are really...
[SPEAKER_06]: but for a major city to, I can't imagine them doing what they were doing with that.
Everything.
[SPEAKER_02]: One of the switches.
[SPEAKER_02]: They're actually going to replace that at that charge for that.
[SPEAKER_02]: This computer back here.
[SPEAKER_02]: The switch that it connects to back there.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we got some weird things going on.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm trying to get a sense of PCNet's supposed to provide me a report of all tickets that were opened.
[SPEAKER_02]: I was going to have him replace the cable in the collector's office, and it's probably the power supply in the computer that got replaced.
[SPEAKER_02]: and he said that he would provide quotes for both of them before any work's done, but that would be my recommendation for being that fixed.
[SPEAKER_02]: I have a temporary cable, so that being the collector's office ran right now, so they're able to function, but it goes up over the door and down.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sometimes when you get these, whether it's a light construct or a car search, you get this randomness of things that it affects, you know.
[SPEAKER_02]: It came through on a network cable.
[SPEAKER_02]: So sometimes it can come in on coax or different things.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's just weird how it works and what it impacts and what it leaves alone.
[SPEAKER_02]: There's no rhyme or reason to it.
[SPEAKER_02]: But it affected literally a network cable that is no longer good that I tested with my tester.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not a cable that was moved or anything that would have caused it, but potentially the switch that it connects to PCS looking at to see if it was impacted.
[SPEAKER_02]: It's not happening.
[SPEAKER_02]: Once I get a better sense of all the issues and if we need to replace some equipment, I'll provide you guys a list of that.
[SPEAKER_02]: But I just wanted to make you all aware of what's been going on since the storm.
[SPEAKER_06]: So do you think it fried her computer?
[SPEAKER_02]: Probably the power supply, and it got toasted.
[SPEAKER_02]: And it's on a surge, so it tells you it can still sometimes impact things.
[SPEAKER_02]: Or maybe a power blip of sorts that caused it to go off, and that's the time the power supply decides to die.
[SPEAKER_02]: But more than likely, that's probably it.
[SPEAKER_02]: So he said he stops his power supplies, and I've got approval for it all.
[SPEAKER_02]: He would take the tower and diagnose it, and then give a quote for it.
[SPEAKER_06]: And that's for PCNet or Euler?
[SPEAKER_02]: Chris Euler.
[SPEAKER_08]: Well, I'm thinking we need to move with Tom the authority to manage this in a way that's best for the county.
[SPEAKER_02]: And then obviously I'll bring him all quotes for approval.
[SPEAKER_02]: He said if it got approved, he would come up and I'd give him this tower to look at, and then he was going to go down to the collector's office and look.
[SPEAKER_02]: from replacing that cable down there.
[SPEAKER_06]: Where would these things be backed up?
[SPEAKER_02]: That's more than likely in Office 365 through OneDrive.
[SPEAKER_02]: So we probably will have access to get there.
[SPEAKER_02]: More than likely, the hard drive was impacted and it was just our supply.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[SPEAKER_06]: We have a motion.
[SPEAKER_09]: I'll second.
[SPEAKER_06]: All those in favor?
[SPEAKER_09]: All right.
[SPEAKER_09]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sounds good.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's all I got.
[SPEAKER_02]: He's going to be in the county here shortly, so as soon as he gets here, I'll bring him in.
[SPEAKER_02]: Sounds good.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh yeah, yeah, I'm sorry, that was the other, I've heard back from one county, Clinton County, and they do not, they do not do it.
[SPEAKER_02]: I haven't heard back from them yet, so those were the two that I reached out to, so I'll try to get an answer for you.
[SPEAKER_06]: And Tom is working on trying to figure out what we need to do for the
Who all needs to be involved in that meeting?
[SPEAKER_06]: And I guess one of us just understand it, since we don't have it.
[SPEAKER_02]: It'd probably be good to just handle a meeting.
[SPEAKER_02]: with them and who else you want involved and then go through it and then I can show kind of the change of moving it to a Microsoft form and then who needs to get noticed.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'll look at my calendar for next week.
[SPEAKER_02]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_06]: Do we have anything else?
[SPEAKER_06]: I have some homework on my desk.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'll make a motion to adjourn.
[SPEAKER_05]: All in favor?